a display of military strength in
Siberia last month Russia could never
show off its cyber arsenal in this way
but as the Foreign Office confirmed
today it has one of tremendous reach and
range these are some of the names the
Foreign Office say are behind the
reckless and indiscriminate attacks on
targets ranging from Ukrainian airports
to UK television stations at the
bustling cybersecurity X conference in
London the UK's first cyber operative
said all signs pointed to a professional
set up it is a day job for these people
you know they are paired members of the
military and their rock up to work just
like you and I would silver day in fact
it was a very interesting feature
through some work conducted by the Dutch
intelligence were actually they were
able to attribute this activity by
hacking into CCTV cameras and watching
people walk into the office they were
able to record the keystrokes of what
they were doing when they were in the
office and then they were when they
would pack up and go home they were able
to watch them leave the office through
the CCTV so it is very much a day job
spear phishing emails designed to trick
users into giving up network access were
employed to target the world anti-doping
agency and the organisation for the
prohibition of chemical weapons
ransomware a malicious virus which
threatens to destroy your files until
you pay a fee was used to attack
Ukraine's Odessa Airport malware
malicious code which allowed Russians to
take screenshots and capture keystrokes
infected the Democratic National
Committee for over a year today the
Dutch authorities also released photos
of the equipment used for close access
attacks on the OSI PW a Wi-Fi antenna in
the boot of a car designed to suck up
employee's data and smartphones
perhaps for hacking into the Wi-Fi
network it's basic that it works I mean
we caught for news at 70 industry APCs
or advanced persistent threats to mean
really advanced really complicated you
know thread actors and advanced
Aksum qualifing that kicks off with a
simple email once attack comes from
anyone with a laptop defense rests on
everyone with the password keep them
strong you don't know how important they
could be brother man Thorpe Sky News